#MeToo MOVEMENT.
AND HILLARY AND THE DEMOCRATIC
HATERS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS ON TONIGHT'S
AND GOLD.
TODAY'S JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH
HEARD HIS FIRST ORAL ARGUMENTS
AT THE SUPREME COURT AND WAS
WELCOMED WARMLY BY HIS
COLLEAGUES.
IN TONIGHT'S MOMENTS OF
COLLEGIALITY WITH YESTERDAYS
CHAOS AND PROMISE FOR MORE.
REPUBLICANS ARE EXUDING MORE
CONFIDENCE WHILE DEMOCRATS ARE
BANKING ON MORE CHAOS.
DESPITE THE BRIGHTEST
CATASTROPHIC LOSS OF
THE SWING VOTE ON THE HIGH
COURT, THEY ARE HITTING THE
ENTER KEY ACCELERATOR.
THESE PEOPLE TRULY BELIEVE THEY
CAN PROTEST THEIR WAY BACK INTO
POWER.
SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT WARNED
OF TONIGHT.
>> THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME TOO
EXTREME.
AND THEY'VE BECOME FRANKLY TOO
DANGEROUS TO GOVERN.
THEY HAVE GONE WHACKO.
IF DEMOCRATS TAKE CONTROL, THEY
WILL TRY TO REVERSE OUR AMAZING
PROGRESS AND PLUNGE OUR COUNTRY
INTO GRIDLOCK, FRANKLY INTO
POVERTY, ULTIMATELY INTO CHAOS.
>> Laura: THE CHAOS TRAIN HAS
NOW EVEN INFECTED WHAT WAS ONCE
THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT.
WHY HASN'T DIANNE FEINSTEIN, WHO
WAS CONSIDERED A SOBER MINDED
LIBERAL, WHY HASN'T SHE
CONDEMNED THE TACTICS AND
INTIMIDATION USED BY HER FEMALE
COLLEAGUES IN THE HALLS OF THE
U.S. SENATE?
DO YOU KNOW LIKE?
BECAUSE PRO-WOMAN DIANNE
FEINSTEIN WANTS TO KEEP THE
ATMOSPHERE RED-HOT, SCARILY SO
TO DRIVE DEMOCRATIC VOTER
TURNOUT.
BUT JUST WHEN YOU THINK THEY
COULDN'T GO LOWER?
THEY DO.
>> TRUMP HAS DELIVERED FOR THESE
PEOPLE ON THE THINGS THEY CARE
ABOUT MOST.
HE HAS DELIVERED RACISM FOR
THESE PEOPLE.
HE HAS DELIVERED MY SAW THE NEED
FOR
THESE PEOPLE.
HE HAS DELIVERED THE
SUPREME COURT FOR THESE PEOPLE
WHICH IS SOMETHING THEY
CONSIDERED FOR A GENERATION.
THEY HAVE CONTROL OF ALL THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT.
WE WILL SEE THIS EITHER FOR 30
DAYS, OR TWO DAYS, OR A THOUSAND
YEAR REICH.
>> Laura: REICH?
NICE.
IF YOU AREN'T ON FOR THE MORAL
DICTATES OF LIBERALISM, THE LEFT
WILL DEMONIZE YOU AS A NAZI,
PLANT FALSE STORIES AGAINST YOU,
TRY TO DESTROY YOUR LIFE.
OF COURSE, THEY'LL TRY TO GET
YOU FIRED.
WHEN YOU ARE PRESIDENT TRUMP OR
JUST A KAVANAUGH -- I LOVE
SAYING THAT.
IF THEY CAN'T BEAT YOU, THEY'LL
THREATEN TO IMPEACH YOU.
HERE'S THE ORIGINAL FOUNDING
MEMBER OF THE CLINTON WARM
WAR ROOM
JAMES CARVILLE.
>> THIS IS NOT GOING TO GO AWAY.
THEY AREN'T GOING TO STOP DOING
STORIES ON KAVANAUGH.
THE DEMOCRATS WIN BACK THE
HOUSE, THEY'LL PROBABLY HOLD
SOME KIND OF HEARINGS ON THE
FACT THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
HE PERJURED HIMSELF DURING HIS
CONFIRMATION HEARINGS TO THE
COURT OF APPEALS.
>> Laura: DEAD OR ALIVE?
I LIKE HIM BETTER, BY THE WAY,
WHEN HE PUT THE GARBAGE PAIL
OVER HIS HEAD BACK IN 2002.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT AFTER THE
LOSS IN 2002?
THAT WAS CARVILLE'S BEST
MOVEMENT          MOMENT.
HOW IS ANY OF THIS GOING TO MAKE
AMERICA'S LIVES BETTER?
WHAT IS THE NEW PLATFORM?
WE'LL SPEND THE NEXT FEW YEARS
AND WILL TORTURE ANYONE WHO'S
REMOTELY ASSOCIATED WITH TRUMP?
PLEASE.
THE THUGGISH WIN AT ALL APPROACH
WAS ON FULL DISPLAY DURING THE
KAVANAUGH BATTLE.
>> DON'T YOU WAVE YOUR HAND AT
ME!
I WAVE MY HAND AT YOU!
HOW DARE YOU TALK TO WOMEN THAT
WAY!
>> WE BELIEVE SURVIVORS!
WE BELIEVE SURVIVORS!
>> Laura: IT'S FITTING, ISN'T
IT, THE WOMEN ONE OF THE
ARCHITECTS OF THE POLITICS OF
DESTRUCTION, ALONG WITH
CARVILLE, HAS NO PROBLEM WITH
ANY OF THAT.
>> YOU CANNOT BE CIVIL WITH A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY WHAT YOU STAND FOR, WHAT
YOU CARE ABOUT.
THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE IF WE ARE
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO WIN BACK THE
HOUSE AND/OR THE SENATE, THAT'S
WHEN CIVILITY CAN START AGAIN.
UNTIL THEN, THE ONLY THING THE
REPUBLICANS SEEM TO RECOGNIZE,
AND RESPECT, AND STRENGTH.
>> Laura: THIS IS SO JUVENILE.
IT'S LIKE YOUR KID, RIGHT --
"I'LL START BEHAVING, MOMMY,
ONCE I GET THE EXTRA PIECE OF
CANDY."
OKAY!
UNLESS THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
POWER, THERE CAN BE NO CIVILITY.
YET THEY ARE THE AGENTS OF
MAYHEM THAT WE'VE ENDURED FOR
TWO YEARS NOW.
THIS IS WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING
SINCE ELECTION NIGHT!
HILLARY WOULD RATHER SEE THE
COUNTRY SWALLOWED UP BY DISCORD
AND ANGER THEN TO ADMIT THE
TRUMP POLICIES ARE ACTUALLY
BEARING FRUIT.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS ALL ABOUT
FOISTING A LIBERAL CONSTRUCT ON
AMERICA.
NO TONALITY, THE SET OF
PRECEPTS, BASICALLY, ABOUT OPEN
BORDERS, OPEN MARKETS, MAY BE
TOSSING IN GENDER VALIDITY FOR
GOOD MEASURE.
ALL OF THAT HAS TO BE ACCEPTED
OR ELSE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE SOFTER,
KINDER HILLARY WE HEARD FROM
JUST TWO YEARS AGO.
>> WE NEED TO GET BETTER AT
FINDING WAYS TO DISAGREE ON
MATTERS OF POLICY WHILE AGREEING
ON QUESTIONS OF DECENCY AND
CIVILITY.
HOW WE TALK TO EACH OTHER, TREAT
EACH OTHER, RESPECT EACH OTHER.
>> Laura: ISN'T THAT NICE AT
THE AL SMITH DINNER?
THAT'S SO NICE.
UNLESS OUR CAMPAIGN GOES DOWN IN
FLAMES, IN OTHER WORDS, AND
UNLESS OUR OPPONENTS FULFILL HIS
PROMISES, IN WHICH CASE WE WILL
SCORCH THE EARTH, CIVILITY BE
DAMNED.
HILLARY COULD NOT LET THE MOMENT
TO PASS FOR BRETT KAVANAUGH TO
HAVE HIS CEREMONIAL SWEARING IN
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE LAST NIGHT.
>> WHAT WAS DONE LAST NIGHT IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS A POLITICAL
RALLY.
IT FURTHER UNDERMINED THE IMAGE
AND INTEGRITY OF THE COURT.
AND THAT TROUBLES ME GREATLY.
SADDENS ME BECAUSE OUR JUDICIAL
SYSTEM HAS BEEN VIEWED AS ONE OF
THE MAIN PILLARS OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL GOVERNMENT.
>> Laura: AND IN WHAT WAY WAS
THIS A POLITICAL RALLY?
I WAS ACTUALLY THERE LAST NIGHT.
OF COURSE PEOPLE ARE EXCITED.
JUST LIKE WHEN DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT GETS TWO JUSTICES OR
ONE JUSTICE?
THEY ARE EXCITED.
IT'S A VICTORY.
YOU CAN'T CELEBRATE VICTORIES,
ONLY FOUR DEMOCRATS?
ALL THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES
WERE SITTING IN THE FRONT ROW,
INCLUDING THE ONE APPOINTED BY
YOUR HUSBAND, HILLARY.
IT WAS A NONPARTISAN MOMENT OF
UNITY AND MAY BE A LITTLE BIT OF
HEALING THAT HILLARY REFUSES TO
ACKNOWLEDGE BECAUSE, OF COURSE,
SHE HAD NO ROLE IN IT.
THIS IS AT THE HEART OF THE
DEMOCRATS' RESISTANCE.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY RESENTFUL THAT
THE COUNTRY IS MOVING AHEAD,
GROWING, THRIVING, RECLAIMING
ITS POWER.
ALSO ON THE WORLD STAGE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO PART IN ANY
OF IT.
BECAUSE TRUMP WAS RIGHT, THEY
WERE WRONG, AND THEY ARE TICKED
OFF ABOUT IT.
LIBERAL DOGMA AND THE GIVEAWAY
POLICIES OF THE PAST, THAT DID
NOT GET US HERE TO REACH
ECONOMIC ACHIEVEMENT AND
OTHERWISE.
LACKING A GOVERNING AGENDA OR IN
THE RESPONSE TO TRUMP'S ECONOMIC
AND GLOBAL SUCCESS?
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE DECIDED TO
RUN ON A PLATFORM OF
DEMONIZATION.
THEY ARE NOW EVEN USING THE
KAVANAUGH VOTE TO PUNISH THEIR
OWN.
DEMOCRAT SENATOR JOE MANCHIN OF
WEST VIRGINIA, IN A CLOSE
REELECTION RACE, AND CANDIDATE
PHIL DRESDEN BEING LASHED BY THE
LEFT FOR THE RESPECTIVE VOTE ON
KAVANAUGH.
THE LIBERAL MoveOn.org CLOSE
ARE
WITHHOLDING MONIES FROM BOTH
CAMPAIGNS OF THE CANDIDATES.
IF THEY WON'T TOLERATE A LITTLE
BIT OF DIVERSITY AMONG OPINION
AMONG THEIR OWN DEMOCRATIC